JAMES Charles
Did an oopsie >:C
Projared update oopsie (yay)
Logan Paul oopsie, is anyone surprised? [Not really]
AND Poppy Gloria [Poppy Harlow and Gloria Borger's son] oopsie, wait, that's me
*6th best anime opening*
Good evening, I'm Poppy Gloria
Welcome to Pew News.
Last week, Poppy Gloria discussed the drama between James Charles and Tati.
*Woosh*
PeWdIePiE dEfInItElY mIsSeD tHe MaRk On HiS vIdEo aBoUt TaTi AnD jAmEs
Think PewDiePie completely missed *the point on that video*
PewDiePie('s) video had no research
I really wish he did more research on YouTube drama
Do your RESEARCH
I think PewDiePie didn't do his research
Due to poor research that does not represent the hard-working esteemed staff here at Pew News
We have decided to let go (of) Poppy Gloria... from our news team and is terminated immediately
wait a minute, YOU CAN'T FIRE ME, I'M POPPY GLORIA GODAMMIT
Good evening ((again)). I'm...Mary...Ham
*Stare*
Excited to jump aboard the new Pew News team
Let's... What can my slogan be?
I like ham *laughs*
(what does that mean???)
So what did I get- I mean, what did Poppy Gloria get wrong from last week?
Well, people pointed out
That James didn't delete the sugar bear hair instastory and when he apologized he kept it up for 24 hours
Well probably because there were (was) some sort of contract
There was a #ad on the upper left corner of his insta-story
Well probably because there was some sort of contract
Sugar Bear Hair is the biggest competitor of Halo beauty and SBH even dissed Tati in a reply... ok
Well it's almost like Poppy Gloria said that in the last video
Tati's product is for health and beauty
Yes the company does do those type(s) as well
But he specifically held up this bag of - bottle of sleep(ing) pills, and that's what he talked about
SO MAYBE YOU SHOULD DO SOME RESEARCH GODDAMMIT
I love Poppy Gloria. She was like a father to me. (aww so sweet)
Clearly, I didn't understand every *laugh* thing about what's going on.
There's a lot of nuances, there a lot of layers, there's a lot of onions
And yes, I brushed over some points just to save time
I didn't want to make another 43-minute video (sick burn)
I didn't talk about how she criticized James for over-sexualizing his content
to a very young audience,
how James has a way of manipulating and getting what he wants.
and Tati obviously being fed up with that.
My point was that I don't think that Tati was completely innocent, and justified in making that video,
and a lot of the stories doesn't add up to me.
As someone from an industry perspective as well, and seeing someone's career being completely destroyed,
over what seems to me, some drama that can easily be resolved between the two of them.
I feel a little bit uncomfortable with that.
Jesus Christ it's still going.
So a lot of people, in regards to James Charles, have been throwing around the word "sexual predator"
Cause allegedly, James Charles has been abusing straight guys into tricking them into being gay
Or abusing his fame and influence or whatever to (per)suade people in their sexuality
The thing, however, that I think is pretty important to bring up is that the person
that Tati brings up in her video saying that oh the waiter, he was straight.
I detail about the things you wanted to do to the waiter
and when I said, "James, he's straight."
Your response was, "Doesn't matter. I'm a celebrity."
Obviously that's disgusting to have some sort of idea that oh "I can do whatever I want because I'm a celebrity"
Ahhhhhhhh
I can also see that being said as a joke, ok?
I don't know. It depends on the context.
Regardless, it turns out, the waiter made a video and he says, he's bi-curious.
[James] invited me out to his hotel
At that time, I was bi-curious.
And when I said, "James, he's straight."
James! He's straight!
Ok, well I guess he wasn't.
So he said that he didn't previously know who James was
I didn't know who James Charles was
He said that he's the one that contacted James afterwards.
The next day my sister convinced me to direct message James Charles
He asked to kiss me and I was very nervous because I've never done anything with a guy
and I was bi-curious so, I said yes.
We ended up making out for around an hour and if I'm being honest
He is the worst kisser. (AHHHHHH)
OOOOOOOOOOHHHHHHHHHH
hehehehehehehehe (school boi laugh)
He's bad at kissing ahaha
So clearly maybe there was other instances, I haven't seen any proof that James has sexually abused
or harassed someone in the sense of trying to convince them that they're gay
Maybe being pushy, yes. I don't know
So at least in this context that Tati brought up that made this whole thing explode, she was wrong about the allegations
The other argument that was brought up to justify this whole ordeal
was that James Charles promo-ed Sugar Bear whatever
You went to Coachella, somehow had a security issue, and magically SBH's there with a contract in hand to save the day for you and all of your friends.
No company would ever go out of their way to have an extra, you know, handful of passes that cost thousands of $$$ a piece
Like just in case~
Companies buy extra tickets all the time. I don't know how Tati doesn't know this
Big companies always gets tickets
If there's anyone that has tickets to events, it's always companies.
So it's not weird at all that they had extra tickets to hand out.
And now it turns out seeing the text of the situation, it didn't seem like it was planned thing or anything
It just seemed like, it happened
But I think it's important to note that because of all this
false allegation(s) came forward with a lot of people spreading around that information as well.
There was this post on twitter, that got 24K retweets, painting James Charles as this sort of predator.
When clearly, this was fabricated and false.
This all started because Jeffree Star - uh - another beauty community person (guru)
*snicker*
Who called James a predator.
Someone that is close, or at least in the circle of James Charles, calling him a predator
seemed to back up that evidence.
Or that idea that he's some sort of predator going after people.
When we know now, there's no real evidence to support that and [Jeffree] even deleted this tweet.
Tati made this video talking about her own brand.
The video has 50 million views, she probably made between 100 thousand to 1 million
of to this video alone, and in sales of this product that she heavily promoted.
It's the top link in the description and there's a card showing up to it, and she talks about it for an extensive amount of time.
This to me sets a dangerous precedent of how much supported it is to make these type of videos.
Even if you don't have all the facts or whatever straight
I don't think this was her intention, but it's pretty crazy.
Now, here's what I think, ok?
I have it all figured out, alright, follow me here.
James Charles is a dumbass, ok?
He promoted these pills as a thank you to this brand that helped him, without thinking too much about it.
He promoted them, or he ignored the fact that Tati might get upset. Either way, the result was the same.
James, under contract, couldn't delete the post right away but just apologized to Tati
Tati got really upset
That's the bad part of Hollywood.
Welcome to show business.
Everyone says what they need to say and uses to who they need to use to get ahead, and I have had about enough.
Tati is fed up with people walking over her, or at least people in the industry doing that to get ahead.
So she realizes, oh I'm gonna do that then, I've had enough of this James guy
I'm sick of him always getting what he wants, I'm sick of him getting away with bad behaviour.
He threw me under the bus, so now I'm gonna throw him under the bus
And instead of calling or talking to James or picking up his calls, she decides she's gonna do this video no matter what
because she's HAD ENOUGH
Not realizing just how massive this thing would be.
In my opinion, if this whole thing stayed in the beauty community, she's would've gone completely fine
But since it's got mainstream, it's clear that people saw through or poked hole in her motives,
she realizes that's it's not at all what she wanted and made this video now to try and stop it.
And that's how all this drama started (detective pewds stricks again)
we can all just pray that we can all like be kind with each other through this
And I'm going to take a time out, and I'm gonna come back, and I'm gonna continue to play with makeup
because it makes me the happiest.
I think this video feels like what the first should've been. There was clearly a lot of anger.
I actually genuinely think that she didn't want any of this consequences.
She hit twice as many subscribers and I don't think she's proudly saying oh "I'm so happy that I got this diamond play button."
It doesn't look like anyone is happy after this whole ordeal.
I don't want you guys to subscribe, I don't want you to feel bad for me,
I don't want you to feel sorry for me. This is not about me.
I don't hate him. I love him.
*pause*
And I don't think he'll get that for a really really long time, and I don't think anyone will
Now, I didn't completely jump on the f*** James Charles bandwagon when I did my first video.
Enough people were doing that I didn't really see a point in it.
I'm not as inclined to throw someone under the bus, because I know what that feels like to happen to you.
And since a lot of things that were presented didn't make sense, I didn't do it as well, and I'm really glad I didn't
because yes, I don't think James Charles is completely faultless. That's not my point again.
But clearly, a lot of these allegations have turned out to be (false), or not as intense as described.
You have all these people that immediately unfollowed
James after this whole ordeal, and people that are pretty controversial figures as well
like Shane, I know Emma Chamberlain and Jeffree,
they're no squeaky clean Youtubers.
Everyone just jumped off the James Charles ship as soon as fast as they could.
James lost a 5th of his audience or more.
His tour is most likely going to be cancelled,
multiple brand deals would likely be cancelled, relationships ruined because of this.
And it sounds to me that he needed some sort of wake up call
and I think this video will actually do him good.
But if the whole thing was worth it? I don't think so, and I still stand by
I think Tati should have just reached out to James to sort it out.
This is what happens when you bring your personal issues to the public
I don't think its a good idea
Next
News
Good Ev-- Good morning actually